um
yeah i was concluding my statement
i had just said that residents aren't
opposed to the scheme
but they're quite you know they've put
very positive proposals forward about
increasing the number of bedrooms in
terms of
dormer roof extensions um
so i think we'll take that into account
so my final
just to sum up i was asking you
please to refuse the application on
grounds of severe effect on neighbours
immunity
failure to consult labels of
pre-application stage
unacceptable effect on neighbours of the
construction phase
inappropriate design of the proposed
building
inaccurate description of the
development and
inadequate parking provision may i
add that if you are uncertain about
granting approval
that you please defer this application
until you've been on a physical psych
visit
i already do say to you that you can
only really appreciate the effect on
the neighbours by going to their gardens
and seeing
what the likely shadow effect would be
i submit that you owe this very least to
the neighbours who have no wits end
about the possibility of the proposed
development being granted permission
thank you thank you
and that concludes the speakers for this
application
um i'll just like to apologize to
everybody for the delay from this
morning
uh i'm happy to call everybody back
again but it was
beyond our control so we'll crack on
with the application if you would like
to start
on this redstone application that's a
long
very many more angles and views um
from the officer's presentation of the
site vision that what we would have ever
seen
go in physically to the site so i'd just
like to qualify that or not
just a couple of questions please to the
office with regard to heights
on page uh well the application states
that the new ridge height
is eight point three meters and on page
fifty three put it points one point
five it says under committed development
right it's a news story could be erected
to a maximum height of 8.5 meters
yeah so that would be higher if this
didn't go through and he did something
under permitted development right is
that correct
uh that is correct but again um rights
there are certain criteria that we'd
have to meet um
which this proposal doesn't currently
need um in terms of that
one only on the principal part of the
dwelling and it's going to be yeah
because i always
also ask with regard to high extent um
the new bridge height is 8.3 meters
how does that compare to the immediate
um other properties in the vicinity
please
um unfortunately i don't have that
information
to handle
uh they are three stories yeah but
in terms of that exact title
yeah so though those properties end to
the right but i have to know
uh information about having smoothed out
right thank you for that um
i mean many of the objections put
forward aren't actually material
planning considerations i mean eg
lost a few would it be used for holiday
accommodation
or the loss of house value and others
which are material
planning considerations eeg noise during
construction they have been covered by
a construction management plan um
i was pleased to see the installation of
solar panels on the roof
that was positive
so before i make a recommendation
i'll listen to our other other committee
members say
that's councillor locke well
i'll check my oh i'll take mine in and
i'll come back to clemson
um i know this site well because i pass
it nearly every morning and i've been
down
on the murals with my dogs i've come
back sometimes longestly
is it i think as the pictures have shown
that we've had
on-site visit yesterday the council lock
of youtube
there's a huge mixture of different
types of dwellings in the area
um kimberly terrace is taller than this
they're definitely taller than this
would be if it was permitted so
and the issues of overlooking for me
well you can see from that that
kimberly terrace overlooks it's each
other's back gardens
and this site as well so there is
overlooking in kimberly church into
their backgrounds
as exists in any of them i do know a lot
of work has been done by
the planning officer with the applicant
on reducing
the hit putting that hip roof on this
one
and no windows and then the privacy
screen which will stop anybody being on
that balcony
looking out over the uh all over the
garden
the other house across the road that we
had a shot from that
has a gable end actually facing that
proposed
this site and as i said it's a gamer
then
it really doesn't look onto the site
even from the uh
conservatory so i was a bit surprised
that
the objections were coming from that
place really but
i think it can easily take this size and
build down here
okay but i'll let you anybody else
council pen into you
thank you chair uh i would just like to
follow up from coachella
on page 53 1.5 vote with the development
rights um and establishing that that
the property under private economic
rights has
a maximum of 8.5 metres but it doesn't
mean anything about the floor here
because the the
new design overall the house is a
considerable size
um and what is the rules for the
developer rights i should know i
apologize that i don't but but can you
just give me a brief
layer right yes you could go up to 8.5
meters but are you going to have a
single story house
yeah so so in terms of class aaa and
part one which is where you can have
an additional story on top and it has to
be on the
principal part of the dwelling so they
could only take three months what ground
will raise
and go up again but this does include
a slight um increase in blood pressure
on the northwest there's an increase
and so in terms of that they would they
wouldn't come under
class aaa and but in terms of the
intention from
the agent um that was established a
pre-application stage
and they initiated
and come in the class okay thank you
and the second point joe may ask um yeah
it's an
issue about no right to to review but
the immunity value
um can you see the sea
from kimberly terrace from kindly
terrace uh ground floor
second floor third floor i would imagine
probably canyons
so if they lose the view of the sea is
that a loss of immunity or is that the
loss of you
so that's an awesome view unfortunately
um in terms of material considerations
um
they lost that view obviously
thank you thank you chair thank you
anybody else like to make consultation
thank you um again on page 53 at the top
it's talking about
um ancillary development and extension
and it does say on point c there being
no
significant adverse impact on the
immediately of the occupants of
neighboring
properties and i would also take the
point that this
is hardly um an hex
or an ancillary development it is
complete refurbishing the house turning
it from a bungalow into a house and i
think the scale of the development
is too large for the for the site
and for the neighbours and i i would
suggest that it would be possible
to get a larger bungalow maybe a dormer
bungalow
and by reconfiguring it and i would
suggest that we reject this and ask him
to come back with
a more appropriate development for the
site
so just in terms of and picking
and so just kind of some character um
the application site is 600 7.3 square
meters
we have kimberly house just above um
kimberly terrace here which is a
two-story
dwelling that sits on a plot of 219
square meters
directly opposite and you have a
two-story dwelling which is 443 square
meters
and then directly behind that another
two-story dwelling at 519 square meters
and and then in the new development
northeast there is a two-story dwelling
at 346 square meters so the actual block
size is considerably larger
than a lot of context and went to
two-story dwellings and
mainly uh currently sits on so in terms
of
plot is too long for the plot the
character would actually establish that
it's much more generous than what some
of the properties
yeah a few things um i'm intrigued this
was called in by my chief executive i've
never known that before and i'd like to
know why that was done
um also i when i first saw this
i thought what's an extension doing
coming
to the planning meeting you know they're
usually fairly small you suddenly
realize it's not an extension it's a
complete new story
they had it and so it's a bit deceptive
when you read that
um i noted from our agenda northern town
council have now um refused it twice
uh there are 18 representations received
number of objections 18. nobody in
favour i know
and when i see when i get applications
like this for an extra story i house not
just a
small extension i always ask myself one
question
would the house be allowed to be built
now as the plan is and i don't think
this one would because there are
numerous problems here
that we've had identified to us and i
think councilman craig is hitting the
nail on the head when she quoted that
on page 53 the policy at the top there
adverse impacts so i
right and well i've written down before
we had to break off earlier
significant harm not for me there isn't
any significant harm
overshadowing well there isn't any
shadowing because
it's to the south of kimberly terrace
for one thing i think that was explained
by the officer this morning and i
mentioned the native
kimberley cherries overlooks a lot of
its neighboring properties
in any of them
[Music]
but i don't see in the conditions a
condition of removing permitted
development rights would that be a
condition
or would that come under some other
legislation well i think that's
important that that will be removed if
the application is approved
condition
[Music]
there
right now if nobody else wants to
comment on it sounded good you tend to
vote please be removed
by myself for approval and seconded by
thank you chair councillor number four
cancer brown councillor christie
councillor craigie against councillor
leather
councillor four tanzania mcgrath
against councillor wiseman four
cancer pennington goods
chair that's five four and
four again so that application is free
thank you
right now i think we've got to get
there's no need to speak
um yeah conflict of interest uh the
applicant is my sister
so i think uh can you give us a call
remember
all right
right and this is presented by future
israel
thank you chef again if then
i'm speaking too badly please just tell
me and i'll try and speak up
and just an application
[Music]
um
again just a wider view aerial image
and the barn and application site is
pointing to the red arrow kind of just
give a wider context
wider area and the ownership
campsite and then there's a residential
properties in the southeast
and two holiday laps direct to the south
and one manager's accommodations
again just another closer image and the
application site outlined in red
northwest you have the list of building
and so um have the holiday accommodation
and the managers
accommodation which were formerly part
of
the farmstead and they they were
converted to
holiday accommodation and management
accommodation and their planning
application
but in 2000 next slide please
here's highway access and the north this
african
this highway leads through the
holiday park and comes out by the
reception
park next slide
and here's highway access to the south
pass the holiday accommodation and
destroying the country lane
as there are a number of access routes
to this bar and
that's two of them shown there
is the bar itself um it's important
condition
moment and as you can see there is a
collapsed
section of that rule there
and again there has been a number of
works taken to um
to make this uh building still stand so
at the end here you have the
mdf uh gate blend just to show you the
condition of the bar
it's quite important
[Music]
um rear section of the barn which is
under the application
here's the front elevation contacts in
context you can see the
front elevation bar on the right there
and then
the holiday accommodation and you've got
the managers accommodation space
on the far end of that building um
like i said before so those barns were
formerly part of the wider farmstead and
they were converted because significant
works including
uh um some time ago
council mexicans again there's an image
of those
um barns which were involved in farm so
and so we have two holiday
accommodations on the right there
management combination at the end
and this is the front elevation context
the listed building
uh manner front elevation
on the left there upgrade to
25 meters next one please
another image of the um
[Music]
this is the view from down the lane and
again this is another access route past
the
listed building
and again this is a view from the other
side of sniffing manner
and so the list are going on right there
and the far left and
just to write that big tree there
and again there's the
[Music]
and finally this is a kind of a view
from that public highway
and at the top of the hill just to show
that
in terms of the wider landscape the barn
is
considered well hidden it's not
beautiful playing the highway
and there is a extensive tree line
between
highway um steel and barn
um so in terms of
impact countryside and then
uh here's the bow sight plan um
new hedge um retention of the stone wall
uh along the side of the smith manor
again this is the existing plans in the
bond
and the both plans
the existing elevations
and those elevations as you can see
there there's a slight increase in
in ridge height and from the existing
bond
material considerations in this case are
the principle of development
design and impact on character
appearance impact
on immunity access highway safety
environmental protection drainage
ecology and planning balance
i hope you've read my um report
recommending
approval for this application if you
have any other questions
thank you anybody like to start the ball
rolling on this
i've got i have no problem i think it's
uh
it's a good use of a redundant bomb
building and it would certainly improve
the setting of sniffing manner as well i
think when it's done
so i'm happy to approve them and cancel
a lot
can we condition and as i've missed it
that it is not sold on the open market
but purely tied to either holiday
accommodation
or workers accommodation could be
conditioned now
it was only advertised to know the
market dwelling um
i don't think there'd be any policy
bases to do so therefore the decision
would be reasonable
uh the policy supports uh there's been a
market and
the application as facebook said hasn't
come in um as a tie
or as a local need or etc so on that
basis my advice would be that the other
people to
have such conditions
i am of the understanding that will be
used as
uh accommodation by the workers
and they put that in their design access
but in terms of uh the description it
came in as open
dwelling and that's what's been assessed
as um
i know in my professional opinion i
believe
it's okay to you know market dwelling um
there's nothing to stress that it can't
be anymore
so we can't condition that in other
words
i know i know no
[Music]
somebody's been proposed by me secondly
by councillor brian
for approval could you take the vote
please yes thank you chad
councillor chancellor brown
or cancer christine or anthony fragie
or penciller leather four councillor
or councillor mcgrath and four
chancellor pennington
or unanimous chairman
thank you swanger and we move on then to
the next
application which is the listed building
uh consent application
we could just speak to this one uh the
ipad
um it's pretty much the same slides um
again and again it's the conversion
advanced dwelling
[Music]
again the location plan the application
side outlined in red
and and showing the arrow here
as you see there the actual site in
relation to the radio
[Music]
barns which have been converted to the
sound
again concepts grade two listed um
asset uh
this is the view from the lane um in
between the
list of buildings and bomb
and again just showing the context from
the bomb and
the way to
[Music]
um
again those plans
the existing elevations those elevations
the material considerations in this case
are the impact on the fabric
setting of the listed building and
ecology
and again hopefully my report sets up
the conversion of the barn
is considered the investment in relation
to the setting of the way to lift
um building and a wider scale
pertaining character importance to the
historical farmstead
and that's what i recommend
[Music]
i'll think of that thank you councilman
anybody else want to make comment i mean
as i said
with the previous application it's going
to improve i think it says
sandra has been recommended buy me from
blue council accepted
communicator yes chair thank you
council about it councillor brown
spencer christie or pence of craigie or
councillor leather or cancel a lot or
cancel the gas cancer pennington
four you know this chair thank you
sandra
could you ask councillor wiseman to come
back
okay
and debbie everybody's going to give
this presentation thanks kevin
e can you come out you'll have
sorry we just got here yeah
it might be better debbie okay
put your chair over near the speakers
um yeah so uh proposal is for
a extension to the rear of the pub
um next slide
so this is the existing situations
you've got flat roofs at the back
um terrace flat roof two flat rooms so
um there was a fence around
it before but that's been removed um so
that's the
private immunity area for the landlord
so yes the photos change the existing
events next slide please
uh so the proposal is uh for a
so for doors out on the kitchen so this
is that first floor level
uh a proposed garden room and then
uh doors onto a part of the flat roof
which currently isn't used
with a fence uh and then to replace
the existing vents on the rest of the
part of it so that's all separate from
the beer garden which is
to the north um
so next slide please the um
elevations show you just see the garden
room from the beer garden looking back
up and from the roadside you can't you
see the roof off the
back of the garden room sorry um and the
fence
going further along towards the other
property
but it's not much different to the
existing situation so
next slide please that shows
the beer garden and where the double
doors are going to be on the kitchen
and then that's the view from the road
back up so the fence will be put back on
um along that elevation
so material planning considerations are
um principle
character heritage assets
residential mainstream ecology um
principle obviously
comes under the residential extension
policy so that's acceptable character
and appearance
it's not much different from the
existing situation
a little bit more defense on their own
side uh
heritage assets not actually enlisted
building
but um the church is nearby
but you can't read the two together so
that's acceptable
uh research community there's a small
roof light
and the neighbor there has commented
that um
in the evenings there may be some noise
but the policy talks about
significant impact and considering as a
pub
and there's already noise and the garden
room is going to enclose
some of that existing situation
and ecology there's no need for any
further reports so
my recommendation would be to approve
the application
anybody like to start the ball rolling
on this one i mean as far as i can see
the main alterations there's french
doors
but you can't see you will be able to
see from the boat
yeah you see the kitchen window that's
there
yeah the garden room will screen those
doors um
[Music]
but there isn't currently a fence there
he's taking that down but um
it will look pretty much like it did
with
[Music]
so is this purely for pride it use or is
it gonna fall part of the pub premises
for his use yeah for the landlords just
google private years
yeah yeah it's uh first of all
accommodation and then he
uses the flat roof
i recommend therefore that the
application is approved
thank
just wanted to ask on page 84
conservation officer middle of the page
no observations does that mean they've
not looked at it
um i consulted um sarah chapel
and um mainly because of the
proximity to the church just to check
that she was okay with it but
yes that was her answer no observations
so
because i pushed for a comment that's
what she said otherwise
i don't think she would have well i'm
glad to see your publishers wishing to
spend some money on it and the
hospitality that's uh looking to do well
so i
would second it if nobody else wants a
second year
cheer thank you councilman
anybody else wants to make any comment
i've got no objections to you
sandra has been moved by council a lot
for approval certainly by councillor
pennington
could you take the vote yes chair thank
you councillor
[Music]
um i had looked at this as a district
councillor i decided not to call in and
my colleague petra hicks has
caught this in so i i feel i'm prejudged
so i will
leave the meeting and be pulled back
with us at the appropriate time
thank you
is there a room i have to go to in this
building i know there used to be a room
there
in the car parking lot
i should have brought my motorhome
um
four speakers down here
um
okay
as i said the next one is uh rally east
and debbie
will give us a presentation
okay so application for um wooden lodge
for holiday net
car parking and access track and the
creation of the new garage and can't
walk for the existing dwelling
so um this is being called in by
councillor hicks
if i have sorry it's been called in by
councillor hicks if the officer is
minded to
approve and
based on it being
proposed residential development which
is too close to a working
with the potential for complaints for
noise
smell hygiene in what is predominantly a
farming area
so a site location plan
shows it in context with
the area um it is quite remote
so in a hamlet east parkwood see the
other dwellings
there there's not many
the access track is adjacent to a
holiday
cottage just left of the axis right
there the other two are dwellings
on the right next slide
please um
this shows the location for the proposed
garage
at the bottom near the house which is
uh listed and then to the north
of the lodge with car parking allocated
that's beyond the existing holiday
lights
using the existing track
um so
it's okay so we've got the garage and a
lodge
um on the same application so i put the
floor plans
on the next slide
and measures about 11 meters
it's the elevations of the dodge um i
haven't got
uh floor levels a dating point on the
plans but i can condition
i think i propose that i condition that
information submitted
prior to commencing
next slide
that's the location for the garage where
the cars are parked at the moment
it shows the relationship with the grade
2 listed
building the conservation
officer has assessed it and
was on the view that is
there isn't an impact there was an
existing structure there
obviously not there now but there was
and it's relatively screened from the
oat with the trees
there there's not really another
location for
a detached garage for the house that
would be more acceptable so
that's considered to be a good
to be okay um next slide please
the sizing for the lodge is in this
parcel of land to the north
it's quite a large area but this is just
for one launch
that's what we're assessing as
on this application is one lodge you can
see the
agricultural farm in the distance behind
the trees
get an idea of the distance between
the two um x5 please
these are the existing holiday let's and
i have
as part of the application a lot of
information has been submitted about the
existing holiday let's
they've got five star reviews they've
been going seven years at least
um consistently so uh
yeah so there's an existing under the
policy there's an existing
um tourism
accommodation
um so um i also requested as part of the
planning application
some information on how it diversifies
the range and i had
three emails back for different
companies
um letting me know that it
will diversify the existing
range of the holiday cottages um to
provide
a sort of more an experience where
people can be more in
in the nature and see um
benefits from the
the low light pollution and things like
that so
as far as i understand it's very uh
it's very good business holiday business
so
the material planning considerations
um the principal development is assessed
dmat policy dm18
as i say diversifying the
access parking on the highway i think in
my report
go into detail but um holiday
uses in the countryside you know
the lanes are narrow and there are
um places where you may have to reverse
if there's a tracks coming
but uh that's the nature of torridge and
we're supportive of tourism
accommodation
and it's only for one lodge which is
what i'm assessing here
so i think in terms of high rates it's
acceptable
character and appearance fine um
no impact on holistic building
residential immunity
it's the holiday lodge and not
residential so it'll have a tie
restricting um it from being permanent
so as far as noise concerns and
complaints go that would be forwarded to
environmental protection
and uh at the moment as a holiday lodge
they have no objections
as long as there's a time ecology
um is fine as the there's a condition
to submit landscaping details
and ground levels and some information
about the materials for the parking area
things like that so that will encourage
has the potential to encourage ecology
on site
um the applicants are very keen on that
anyway
and then flooding drainage um
there's provision there for that
and i went out and videoed the water
course and it was running
and uh the applicant actually worked for
the environment agency so i'm sure
um he will make sure that that there's
suitable provision for drain
so my recommendation would be to approve
the application
yeah with the various conditions
attached on as i say
further detail about wow levels
excavation
landscaping
thank you thank you for that we've got
four speakers listed for this
application and the first one is david
smith
speaking on behalf of the parish council
we'd like to stand
somebody that young spot
me please you have three minutes to
address it okay thank you
uh the parish of western
east brookwood is a small community in
our
agricultural areas the majority of our
roads are single track
and poorly maintained there's no village
shop
there's no post office there's no public
house there's no village hall
the village school closed in 2013.
the nearest facilities are four miles
away and now the bad weather
and the proposed development is a mile
at least a mile from the nearest main
road
on main road i mean one with two lanes
rather than a single track
people can't just walk to the shop to
get a loaf of bread or nip to the pipe
for
into the pub for a pint or for a meal
with a family
virtually every journey has to be made
by car
so even a small development has a
significant impact on the roads and
that's a major concern of the parish
council
the area simply can't support additional
tourism business
and traffic and brookford itself as a
parish and being quite parochial here
but will gain no benefit from this
development it won't bring any income
into
but it won't help the facilities if
granted it would also be the third
additional property
granted on this site where does that
stop
the proposed site is in close proximity
to a neighboring cattle shed
which would not be allowed if it was a
residential property
rather than for holiday use
the proposed proposal is also for a new
building
and it was very residential use it was
also not be allowed rather
than this is for holiday use and i find
that a little incongruous
that we can say we can recommend the
granting of an application
for a property in the middle that i'll
come onto the location at the moment
that oh it's okay for for holiday use
rather than residential use
so it's okay to impact maybe 30 40
families coming on holiday
instead of just one family living there
all the time i don't think that's good
for the reputation of torridge
the map accompanying your committee
report shows that
the site is also boarded by a
medium-sized dairy farm on the other
side
with associated slurry tanks adding to
the noise
smell and fly nuisance and you can see
from that map in the pictures how close
the log would be to the adjacent cattle
bar
one of the neighbors have real and
genuine concerns
that if poverty makers complain about
the noise and smells from this farm
they will be forced to curtail their
business
the parish council was unanimous in its
objections is that this application
and it's both interesting and
significant to know there have been no
separate or independent comments made in
support of it
i'd also like to highlight that to my
knowledge three tourism related
businesses
located in western east brooklyn has
ceased trading in the last few years
and that's not due to covert and that
suggests to me that the area cannot
support or sustain tourism
it's too remote i therefore without this
committee to support the local parish
council
in refusing this application thank you
for your time
thank you our next
speaker is mike spencer
member of the public speaking against
the application
well i trust that you have a copy of the
map that you should have should you copy
that yeah
[Music]
right the only provision for a lodge to
be considered
is by offering diverse accommodation
which the applicant
claims will be an at one with nature
experience
to appeal to those wanting to enjoy the
wildflower meadow and its wildlife
and or stargazers if you look at the map
you will see that the lodge would be
approximately
20 to 25 meters from our cattle and
sheepdogs
cattle were housed here from september
to may creating noise from
cows following heavy metal doors and
gates clanging
metal feed troughs scraping on concrete
tractor with lover
moving big bales of hay and straw
this is daily including saturdays and
sundays
and this could be very early mornings
and then again events
at weekends there's extra work blocking
out the shed with tracker and much
brother
lights are on in the cabin bars
throughout the evening and night
and the sheep bomb during landing and
night feeding
this will certainly have an effect on
any star density
the lodge site is directly adjacent to
images field
the only field to access the buildings
from all our fields
year round we regularly drive livestock
through near to the buildings for
routine
animal husbandry with lots of hollering
and shouting going on
on market days this happens from 6am
with extra noise from rattling trailers
and loading lifestyle through the summer
this field is the main route for all the
machines
that's usual for any agricultural
business it's like lots of industry it's
noisy
the applicant says rally barn is closer
to our small holding boundary than the
lodge
looking at the map this wording is very
misleading
as the only thing rally barn is close to
is the fence
on our front drive it's a significant
distance from our livestock buildings
and the lodge site
which are up a steep slope and beyond
other buildings
he says he's not received any concerns
from visitors
in raleigh barn about our agricultural
noise or smell
and the reason for this is very simple
rally barn is nowhere near
our agricultural activities the proposed
lodge
is on the greenfield site so no one's
been there to experience the
agricultural laws
anyone with any agricultural knowledge
and experience
would know this is a bad idea as
demonstrated by your
environmental officer not allowing the
residential permission
due to problem probable nuisance
the applicant has however received
concerns from tourists
in raleigh barn about short-term
building work on the front of our house
and this was only weekdays in normal
working hours
thus it's certain that tourists come in
for an act one with nature experiences
when subjected to agricultural noise
at unsocial hours and weekends in a
wooden building
would lead to very dissatisfied visitors
to torridge
can i actually do one helping somebody
yes it's
finished hence this site is not
compatible with this alleged
diversification
okay thank you
the next person the statistic is yolanda
spencer
thank you
though promoting new activities it's
important torrance's core rural farming
history is protected about adverse
effect on existing farm operations
this is in the adopted local plan
further policy references are from the
planning consultant mr mike
kelly a holiday lodge cited so close to
livestock buildings would cause conflict
between the uses
especially given the applicant's
statement that it's to be an
at one with nature experience enjoying
the wildflower meadow with
wildlife and or stargazing
policy dm1 amenity considerations
recognizes the need to safeguard the
amenities of occupants of properties
whether impermanent or holiday
occupation
policy dm18 tourist accommodation
includes c
diversifies the range or improves the
quality of existing tourist
accommodation
the applicant relies that riley barn
with residential condition
has been occupied for holiday lettings
it's not the intention of policy dma
team to allow new tourism accommodation
whenever a residential property happens
to be used for holiday letting
this argument could be repeated on any
rural site
choosing to use residential dwellings
for holiday vets
barley barn unlike holiday-conditioned
buildings
could revert back to residential at any
time
riley cottage is not a holiday let it's
residential commissioned
and only ever occupied as a permanent
home there's a website mentioned
but it's been unavailable for over seven
years
further policy dm18f requires additional
tourist accommodation to respect
and enhance the key characteristics of
the relevant landscape types
the proposed largest on a greenfield
site and divorced
in the african other buildings will not
meet this requirement
how can a building enhance a lovely
green field
it also sets the precedent for further
similar development
on undeveloped land with this or
subsequent owners
in the agenda report residential roofs
has not been ruled out
and the applicant's original intention
was for residential use
this would lead to statutory nuisances
that council's environmental protection
officers
seeing the site unsuitable for a
dwelling has its such close proximity to
livestock buildings
with our first impact from noise over
and fly nuisance
it follows that even if the proposed was
considered to comply with the
m18 which is not considered to be the
case
to allow a holiday lodge on the site
which has no
functional link with other existing
rural activity
does not make sound planning sense
also the diversity claim is flawed as it
won't meet these ideas
because of proximity to livestock
buildings and fields
with industrial type noise and light are
unsociable hours
given the sighting of the proposed
holiday launch on undeveloped land
and with no existing buildings and
within 20 to 25 meters of our farmers
livestock operation
members may wish to satisfy themselves
on the above points by undertaking
a site visit before making a final
decision
thank you very much for your time thank
you
our final speaker for this is miles
thomas
in support yeah you have
three minutes as well thank you good
afternoon my wife and i bought the
property of raleigh eight years ago
once he originally farmer stayed in his
cockpit the listed 16th century long
house is in a very poor state and then
you'll have to just keep up because you
can't
sorry uh the 1670 longhouse is a very
poor state of repair the land was
overgrown and most of the farmland had
been sold off
despite this we knew we found something
special
our vision from the outset was for a
small but quality branding friendly
holiday business so we took over two
years renovating the site
as a professional environmentalist it's
important to me to develop the whole
site in a sustainable way with a minimal
carbon footprint
to target the market for this type of
accommodation
my wife and i are proud to achieve a
site that was considered to be carbon
neutral
and a successful environmentally
friendly holiday that has achieved
recognition
such as a green tourism gold award as
well as becoming a beverly bias leader
business plan
because of their success we'd like to
diversify what is available to holiday
cash by building
a one-bedroom wooden holiday lodge to
provide a slightly quirky style
accommodation
focused on wildlife and the natural
environment to complement the existing
buildings
to be clear we have no desire to build
any more than this as this will destroy
the experience that we're trying to
create
the planning office's report shows that
the application supports a wide range of
local and national planning policies
indeed the support of many of these
policies particularly around climate
change and sustainability
are of personal importance to me
to comment on the reasons for this
calling our neighbors are concerned that
smell and noise generated bodyguards
business and smallholding would give
rise to complaints from holiday makers
there's no evidence that this would be
an issue that the evidence suggests
otherwise
our existing holidays is about 10 meters
further away
from the nearest livestock building than
the proposed lodge will be
and nearer to the maintenance shed and
small holding entrance
however it has generated over 100
independent online reviews
not one of which mentions noise or
smells
indeed if we found this likely to be a
problem we would not want to invest in
the construction lodge
after his struggle to make a financial
return
however it is true that we once in the
past eight years had to talk to our
neighbours who requested a domestic
volts stop barking very early in the
morning when builders were allowed to
construct an extension
this they kindly sorted out immediately
to summarize we don't believe there is a
significant or beneficial evidence that
the proposal will have a negative effect
on
any other local businesses local area or
wider environment
genuinely the project will have many
benefits it would be temporary
employment during initial construction
supplier both strategies local and
obtained all of their non-structural
wood from within devon
we need to complete a required seasonal
work to assist with changeovers
it will help us and the future is to
maintain the heritage asset
and it will of course contribute to the
local tourism economy thank you very
much
thank you
all right well that was our last speaker
for this application
we would like to start the debate on
casablanca i mean yeah
very important so concern would be that
that that nothing happens to in any way
cause any aggravation
for the neighbouring farmers in the
sense that if holiday
people you know people there already did
start to complain about issues
because there is although that's only a
small holding there there is
you know a dairy farm quite close to the
side and another one not that far away
either so
noise and smells in agriculture is
you know it does happen and you know
i was actually thinking the opposite
because if you if you book a holiday
in the countryside you would obviously
find out and know that it was near
the farm and expect the smells of the
countryside
i think anybody booking this type of
holiday would be
aware of all that um and i think this
would really appeal
to all those has been said so back to
nature holiday
yeah i will support what counselor brown
said um
and i've been married to the dairy farm
for 48 years and i still live on the
farm
so i'm very very well aware of all the
noise and what goes on throughout the
year on
dairy farms and i agree with council
margaret brown
if you look at you don't just book up a
holiday cottage you go
on their website to see where it is and
if you want a holiday like this
in the remote part of the country to
experience the country life
that is exactly where you would go
so i too would support the application
that's the question
it can ask a couple questions um one of
the speakers said there'd been a
previous
planning application on this site for a
permanent house
yeah i looked at the planning history
and i couldn't see that i don't know if
that's true or not
and the other question is um if this is
isn't a permanent house if it is just
for holiday makers
and do they have the right to complain i
thought it was only
residents complain is there only there
temporarily then
surely they have no right to complain
can anybody answer that so the advanced
were converted to residential from their
holiday that
that that's the argument that's being
raised is that they shouldn't they
should be
they shouldn't be allowed to be awesome
permanent residential application
i think they're referring to the
conversion from two
farms at that time it was decided
to uh approve them as residential wealth
and holiday there
um let me ah sorry sorry the person who
spoke said it was on this
site it wasn't referring to it
no there's no application for where the
lodge is
one of the arguments is that those
holiday
sorry the cottages that exist have been
approved for residential
not holiday and so
the existing point doesn't
exist in life because it's approved
so anyway that that's that um the other
question was
um holidays
yeah because with the holiday time they
wouldn't have an issue with it
so temporarily though these people are
staying temporarily
so it would have to be full residential
for it then to have serious outcomes on
the adjacent farm but that's not what
we're looking at here we're looking on
holiday
use with a tie to prevent that
design and access statement on the plan
in portal
um they have got the green tourism gold
award
um and they've got 60 annual occupancy
in their um their lesson and they're
also
members of the north devon biosphere
partnership
they remember when we looked at a
holiday
and accommodation place at heart that
was also mentioned and we did
you know make quite an important
statement about that being part of the
biofeed partnership so i think that's
another you know
good thing for this holiday
accommodation
i think and also we saw the
proposed site for the garage and
cartwalk and i think i did see a
photograph there had been a garage there
before
before it was demolished i've got no
problem with
that in that location the the sighting
of the holiday launch
uh do you know how far it is from the
boundary of the farm
get it the cable
[Music]
man
i think it's
about 15 years as well
i mean i do i do take the point about a
rocking farm in the working environment
and the activities that go on there and
now
um but i think i agree with councillor
locke said that
if you're looking for the holiday lodge
you compare exactly where it is and
what's in the area
and if if there's a farm next door you
don't and don't want to be near it
you know council wise thank you chair
um yeah that
way i've taken that correctly right um
somebody's staying renting a holiday
lodge making
walls complaint has virtually no weight
yeah correct can i come back
to clarify um clearly we have an
environmental protection officer here
today and that would come under the
environmental section legislation so i
don't know
um the ins and outs and what that is the
case uh the constitutional response
indicates that
as um tourist transient transient
that they wouldn't complain necessarily
and it's more likely something from my
experience that they can think about
tripadvisor so along those lines as
opposed to actually
uh formal potential that requires at
that time but as to whether
lawfully
because obviously i've got a great
sympathy with the fact that the
launch is only 15 to 20 meters or
whatever it is away from the farm
um i think that that potentially could
be significant but
that's without weight to a great extent
but the fact that we are supposed to be
providing or hoping to provide the
future
top quality holiday accommodations to
grow our economy it's a one growth area
we have
so on balance i think it's a difficult
decision but i think
over at the moment i'm leaning on coming
down to support this application for
that reason
i think one of the things that's been
answered for me is the fact that is
a holiday lodge occupation it's not an
occupancy
it's not residential it can't be used as
a permanent presence it's a holiday
um
i hear the objections from the farm
business but
i think as our planning managers said
most people if they're
as a holiday any kind of holiday
accommodation and they have a problem
with it they'll complain either to the
owner of the accommodation or trip
advisor whoever it may be
i don't know actually following a local
council
i don't accept the concern though from
the farm
about the effect but i mean
i as black council wiseman said we all
we are hoping to increase and improve
our holiday offer and these lodges are
very popular
and i wouldn't thought anybody's going
to make that kind of an investment
if you don't think you're going to be
very successful
in planning terms it isn't you know
it is an old hybrid auction scene
but i think because it's the holiday
accommodation
and i think it's council lobster people
want remote paris
[Music]
in a nice accommodation in some modern
type of competition
so yeah that's what i've got to say
present
i'll move approval questions
one second council greatly said i think
council brown recommended to prove
that right
[Music]
or chancellor wiseman or
chancellor pennington oh sorry
seven four and one against chair thank
you
yes
okay we'll move on to our next
application which is 7g
we chose the application
and we had a side visit to this one as
well as
angelo and this presentation thank you
from the chair with our new members
and i'm here to present the outline
applications
and senior dwelling at stakeholders
okay
so apologies for that can you hear me a
bit clearer
okay so um
the uh slide before you shows an aerial
image of chillsworthy as a whole
with the site indicated by the red arrow
and to the immediate right-hand side is
the development boundary map
for tools worthy to show the uh the
extent of
the settlement as a whole and the
relationship of the site to the uh
proposed development boundary of
chillsworthy where the site is
located to the northeast settlement
approximately
you can have the next slide
so here's a zoomed in aerial image to
show the sightings a
parcel of agricultural land that will be
served
accessed immediately from the highway
that runs from
north to south from bradworthy down to
polesworthy and it comes off
on a shared access that leads to a byway
highway 15 that can provide pedestrian
access
through to the center of chile's world
into access
services within the community hall that
provides a provision of
recreational sports facilities as well
as a social club
and then and then agreeing of tools
worthy
and then through to the site as well you
can see it's
a shared access that's shared by
two existing dwellings known as slate
cottage as well as dovecot
as also the existing site has a local
use
as an agricultural access and uh to the
south of the site as you can see on the
location plan to right
there's a southwest water treatment
works plant as well which is served by
maintenance vehicles currently and next
slide
here's an indicative site layout plan as
as outlined previously this is an
outline application so all details
should just be
supported and come at a later stage the
plan indicates that a dwelling can be
comfortably accommodated within the
proposed boundary
the site and next slide
please here is uh
photos for showing the visibility
displays from the highway the classified
highway
um which shows there is a sufficient
degree
of view on either
display next slide please
here is a view um from the highway
looking
towards the access road that's shared
and
we've immediately in front of you is a
slate
court and there into the writers of
byway
which is also shared access for some
other
residential dwellings next slide please
so here is to the left this is the
entrance to the site
um which is known as slate
court which is comprised of slate
cottage
and which also has the stone boom to
front view as an annex that serves
that main dwelling and then within the
site you'll see
which is an independent dwelling in its
own right a former bar
a stable that was converted and then to
the right here
shows the byway that leads into the
center of chillsworthy and also
there's a provisional parking turning
for some
dwellings there as well next slide
please
so the left-hand side it shows a view
into
the center of slate courts into the
informal
uh parking and turning area courtyard
and that's views taken by the entrance
where the gateway is
and then the photo on the right hand
side shows a
image looking back towards the entrance
so you can see
the annex in the distance and the
existing access arrangement
next slide please so here is a view
looking immediately at the site entrance
which
serves as the existing agricultural
access which
contains a redundant well
this used single-story building stone
building
and then on the hand side shows a view
of the informal courtyard area shared
between the existing dwellings
as well as the access to the southwest
water treatment line
next slide please um
so this is just give an indication of
the access that
shows uh leads on to the southwest water
treatment plant
okay now this is within the site on the
left hand side
is in the southern along the southern
boundary to show the existing
arrangement of the site
and then beyond the site to the north
and then to the east
as a view is the outlook aspect from the
site as well
next slide please
so for the photos from the left on the
left hand side shows a view within the
site from the northern boundary
to show the um mature trees and hedgerow
boundaries established as well as the
existing building um and then on the
left
on the right hand side sorry it's just a
close-up of the building and the
existing
field entrance that would be back into
the informal
the courtyard turning area
and next slide please
so the material considerations in this
case is the principle
of uh development and the site as in the
officers report the site is considered
reasonably well related
to the development boundary and setting
the matures worthy
and and it can provide as well
reasonably connected by um
sustainable modes of transport through
the public byway
linking to the existing services and
facilities
the character and appearance of the site
the details of this
would come within the latest stage in
reserve matters
however it's considered in principle
that the site could respect
and retain the uh the real
characteristics associated with
the spatial strategy policy of um
chillsworthy which is h08
um the immunity consideration
uh the site there was concerns raised
with regards to the residential
use of the site having considered the
existing arrangement of the site with
two
in planning terms to individual planning
units the arrangement of the southwest
treatment plants and access to the site
the use of that particular field is
considered to have a
sufficient degree of separation from the
private community space
of the existing dwellings and thus
considered to be able to
function independently without resulting
in any
significant immunity harm nonetheless
their concerns were raised with traffic
movements
passing the proximity of the existing
dwellings
and the annex and it was considered that
this the harm of this
and the consultation with environmental
protection officer the disturbance would
likely come through the construction
phase therefore it's been recommended
that a construction
management plan to control hours of
operations
and when deliveries come to um
mitigate that potential harm was
considered acceptable
in this instance and then the
the highways impacts can certainly
raised by
some um interested in third parties but
in this instance highways
authority providing standard advice that
displays access and the site is
sufficient
and the arrangement through the site is
considered
as more of a an immunity consideration
as it gets a highway
per se uh consideration the
environmental
impact uh it's been conditioned that's a
phase one contaminated land survey would
be provided
as the existing building on the site
would
be demolished as a part of the scheme
also the
as the wider aspects its former
agricultural use
it was recommended that that condition
was imposed by the environmental
protection team
as foul drainage will connect to a main
system that links into the sewage
treatment plant
critical drainage the site is within the
critical drainage area
and concerns of race about surface water
flooding
and this detail is considered to be
reasonable
to be assessed within the reserve matter
stage to mitigate
through an attenuation system that's
deemed
appropriate at the time managing the
surface water
ecology the site is potential
there is no significant harm opposed to
protective species
unless it's been proposed a net gain can
be delivered through the scheme
of the provision of a bat and bird box
on balance the application does sit
outside the development boundary
of chillsworthy nonetheless given our
five-year supply position as
an authority the site is considered to
be reasonably well related
and thus can support the retention of
uh existing community services within
the tools whether the spatial strategy
policy h h0h
and st07 um and
the other considerations as outposts
raised to barbara considered to be
either capable of being mitigated
through the various conditions proposed
so i'll pass you back to the chairman to
to ask any questions as you see fit
thank you
for listening thank you angela
we've got one speaker
company i thought the presentation
yesterday did capture it really well
thank you um the only thing was missing
was the
turning going light over the development
which was much more severe than the
tournament i'm only here because country
watson's got me in it
i'm here as a support member not some
member of the public
so i'll just read what i've been given
to read and i will not pass any comment
on it
okay thank you the access to the site is
through a private property over a
domestic gateway
driveway gated driveway using the
private agreement that is limited to the
owners of the agricultural land
it is not and never been a public right
of vote for at least 40 years that we
know of
this has been recognized as an
agricultural right of way
as the phrase in the deed says for
cattle and other animals
and vehicles implies as the field was
designated for agricultural use
no other type of development would have
been visualized
there is fast difference between the
agricultural use and the domestic use
and the pros of the proposal would
create an unacceptable increase
in the level of traffic over our
driveway the hours of use would increase
intrusively so the safety of ourselves
and our credence and our pets
will be much reduced the drive is inches
from the front door
both the house and state board state
court bond
the domestic driveway does not have a
dedicated pedestrian access
or protection of any enforceable speed
limit
state court is a family property with
three generations living in three
properties around the communal courtyard
this application has made a huge
reduction in privacy
and security and compromise on
legitimate enjoyment of our properties
we would in fact have no property
no control over who enters our property
there is going to be extra knowledge
generated any of the day or night
by new residents household extra cars
visitors gardening equipment
oracles etc up to now this has been a
quiet rural property but the proposal
tries to turn our driveway into a public
thoroughfare
which totally changes its character it
would have a negative effect on the
value of our properties
the detrimental effect extends to the
use of the enjoyment and profitability
of our rental property i've also been
asked to add
there was a planning permission for st
cottage for folk at
state cottage for five dwellings that's
the cottage the annex
um i don't know what that says sorry
caravan and state park this is not
is is this not the limit to a number of
dwellings
on a private driver i think those
comments are
merited by the remarks in your from the
parish council
i'm all for parish councillors and town
councils come in and address them
and i always want district councillors
to have the chance to be an award member
they'll be addressing the committee but
if somebody stands up as a war member
and speaks for an independent
person it'll be easy with
yeah i read through this um it's all
about the chills worthy boundary and so
on
what made me was i looked at my map that
i've got here
and i looked at that and there is
absolutely no mention
in our agenda today that this is
development in the open countryside
it's surrounded on three sides by fields
and yet there's absolutely no reference
to it um
and i i was just surprised to see that
because it strikes me this is like it's
like a finger protruding into the
countryside and it's going to be the
nail on the end of the finger pushing it
even further into the comforter
you look at your map i can't see any
buildings around
three sides of it so can i ask why there
was no reference to that because that's
the thing that really struck me and
supposed right
sorry
paragraph 1.1 except sound that the site
is
in a countryside location beyond any
uh will identify the settlement
and therefore the principal development
ordinarily
would just be supported because it goes
beyond the chillsworth
there's a native development boundary
and then
the report goes into discussing
[Music]
um
expand on how well this proposal relates
to the spatial strategy policies
but it is an open countryside proposal
that we now considering it
given this proposed reasonable
relationship
to boundary and existing built ball
materials really that's why
we address it in terms of those spatial
strategies
it bears
but as with any five years by that's
outside of academic boundary
we assess its relationship to existing
settlements so
any development outside of that family
would be
open countryside developments
thank you for that but uh i still regard
it as developing in open country and i
can't support it
because uh you can see from the map
there that it clearly
is completely surrounded by open
countryside
and i i'm not going to be held hostage
on a five-year
housing supply either because we are
still allowed to turn it down it isn't
just
you know oh yeah we haven't got five
years we must pass it
i don't think this one actually fits the
criteria
thank you council christie you really
have sniped your name coming to them
yeah i think i might um disagree with
came to brizzy my one
concern is when i see highways
had no objections but the footpath
officer
has spoken very strongly on page 104
that the footpath should stay open and
available at all times
is that something we could condition
should the application be passed please
um i believe an informative should be
attached to the application informative
one
that informs the action or developer
that
the public might have ways should remain
open at all times
during the construction phase it doesn't
mean
the development of whatever recognition
comes up today
doesn't close or restrict that if
within the construction management by
the stage if it was to
get that car they would require to
divert or
temporarily um divert the public rights
way they need to apply to seven county
council
for the relevant permissions to do so
so it could be they could temporarily
diverted by each
they they need to seek to
keep it open throughout the whole
and the operation to it being
i would like to see that conditioned in
the second edition rather than
as part of the constructed management
plan
well i'll discuss that with
my manager ordinarily it's been
practiced to
have it as attached as an informative to
advise
the
right away technologies
guys yes sure um
i think uh lobbyists could put as a
condition
and we'd have to look at the wording of
that to allow it to be closed
um for temporary period if there's an
alternative which would be acceptable to
devon county council
they wouldn't need consent democratic
council to do that as well to tie that
up
um but i think the principle that
where they put it right away within a
slight outline would be acceptable
um so we could include that but we'd
have to have a look at that wording
and maybe we can come back to the chair
and try to share with that wording
um i i personally see this bump right
away being lost
for a long time to be honest so i'm not
a favorite application so i like the
second encounter with christie
and again again it's country it's
opening countryside i don't agree with
it
as you see the picture in that as you're
coming in and that's going to pop it
right away going there you put a
dwelling in there you're going to lose
that problem right away
so regardless there's always a character
devon county that
maybe get another one additional but
through um it's open countryside and i
don't agree with it
too many years stepping through the net
and what i don't like about the
condition on the counter locks it
it's obviously going into the management
plan i really do struggle when we put
things into management plans
or confidence because i've seen those
rapid knots
and when it goes to that late stage in
the application it's too
too far then so i mean i support cancer
christie my second is
ocean
did you make to refuse
[Music]
recognition of approval uh we do need a
statement of
reasons for that and the policies
included
well before we get to that i have a few
comments to make as well
i went on google maps and looked at this
yesterday
uh amazing what you can see on google
maps and zooming in on things
and then it's perfectly right it is
inaudible
and it's a little triangular piece
almost of land
tucked in the corner unbalanced i really
haven't got a problem with it but i do
wonder about st07 because at the bottom
of
page 106 at 1.3 where it mentions stl7
and the reasons seo
the policy of sd07 nonetheless
the final sentence nonetheless
it is considered that due to the site
location none of these provisions apply
in this case and the proposed
development is not supported by
ballistic
sto7 then when i was reading further
through it all
at the bottom of page 111 at 8.4
let's sorry 8.5 the proposed development
is considered to record with the
provisions of policies
without the compliance but
is
and then following that initial
paragraph was 3.1
it sets out our current position with
that
following the verb appeal where we are
now in terms of
we have to be located through policy st
that's why initially it would say it
doesn't cause
sta7
i'm
another um i recommend that the
application is approved subject to that
additional cause
to be agreed by the gerund buyer's chair
to keep the book
as it is i don't think the public right
away is going to be
lost with us
and if we make that a condition that
counts with what mentioned and
our planning manager says that can be a
foundation rather than just an informed
um one small dwellingness
and i don't think it's going to affect
any of the other they talk about privacy
and
various issues but i don't think it
affects anybody and
security mentions security it's not
planning issues
in that respect and we thought somebody
else did in theirs
the security area but anyway
it's been known by council christie
sent me back out of the god to refuse
but we've not got the reasons for that
if if that's successful we'll need some
reasons
[Music]
um
yes i just want to
clarify this side element as we
discussed
um and the officers report uh the
obviously report
service at 1.19 and we all agree
it's here so that's not for debate
um the issue is from the five year house
land supply and i'm not going to go
across
grounds we all have a little idea how to
multiply
but that does mean that we need to have
a look at
the impacts of the department um
and the adverse effect would have two
significant
demonstrably outweighed benefits and
that's what we're looking at those
adverse impacts
so members need to consider what those
adverse impacts are for those adverse
impacts landscape community highways but
they may be
that's what needs to be the statements
and then a statement about why
those impacts uh wants to outweigh the
benefits for the additional
dwelling so it's that balance that
members need to consider
um
um i mean my concern is as council
christine carlsbad often said is that
you know either you've got a development
boundary you haven't got a development
boundary
and if you're gonna sort of if we're
gonna keep sort of
allowing these developments just over
the edge where does that stop
i mean look if you look in children
there's all manner of places they could
keep going
to my concern really well there is all
over the district that applies all over
the district
i realize that yeah as as the planning
managers just
explained we've got to look at this
balance because we've not got
and i know it's a nuisance for a lot of
for a lot of consideration but we've got
this balance that we've got to consider
and
one dwelling attached to a development
barrier like this one looking at
children
how detrimental is it to the area to
allow that as opposed to the benefit
to providing housing even if there's
only one
that's the balance we've got to make now
is it so detrimental
to allow this in that location and it
outweighs the benefits
that's that's really what you want i
the
and the argument being
councillor christian the argument being
it's
detrimental look
at the balance of this proceeding but
you believe it's more detrimental than
cancer
medicines to allow it to turn it down
into that you know detrimental to the
air right
it's a greenfield development we've all
uh sorry
development in the open countryside
we've all agreed that we're just gonna
um say that but
my problem with it is that when as
council bound just said when we stop
because
this one is clearly not very well
related to the village at all
it's an extension of an extension
you can see that already that's the
places like i don't like it i mean the
one that we looked at that came to the
bench that was a different application
altogether
that was turned down for the reasons
council
raised this this to me doesn't fit in
exactly
can i just can i just go back and state
one which we probably all remember
which i must admit surprised me at the
time this was
uh in benefit it was uh three houses
across the road from londonderry estate
which has got 300 houses
literally across the road you know 15
foot
and yet when that went to appeal the
inspector said yeah that's in the open
countryside you can't have it
and this is even more that was when we
had our
five-year housing months ago it was but
as i've said we
don't have to we don't agree with
everyone do we
we don't that's true or not
you know you could compare it to all
sorts of different
sites and what decisions we've had but
it's got to be
you know every application on its own
you know you can go on comparing a b c d
but we are here to discuss this
application
on its own merits
[Music]
with regards to the public by the way on
the previous images where the tree line
was going from north to south
where everyone's on the back of the
existing some existing dwellings and
that
is approximately about half kilometers
to
access into a community hall
whether the recreational sports
facilities and social paperwork so
in terms of its relationship to serving
existing community resources and
facilities it's
considered to be quite accessible and
related
single photos to the right so
it will serve as a means of brightness
way for
the proposed occupiers to access
services and facilities
okay councilman
on this application of zelda merit and i
think it's detrimental to the open
countryside
and that's why our second council
christie is purely based on this
not previous or future stuff going
forward but i do feel
we need to set a president that we don't
have to accept everything it comes
forward but purely on this application
i'm not for it right has anybody no
well it's been proposed by council of
christian second the council would love
to refuse it
because this is in the open countryside
and even recognizing the balancing
process it should be refused sandra
could you take the vote
just to be clear we voted for refusal or
against refugees
that's created on this boat this is a
proposal to refuse
okay that's
[Music]
for refusal
[Music]
[Music]
with migos or chancellor wiseman
yes that's the pennington against
that's three four and six against chair
thank you sandra wright will take the
other proposal
to to approve this which council a lot
look forward
sending that councillor brown would you
take that law for approval of the
applicant
yes thank you chairman sorry
[Music]
the word interview agreement resulted in
the vice chair
on the books right away
you want me to go through the list of
conditions yes so yeah i just lost
because it's gone around so many times
i've got what because
is maintained open unless it's agreed
otherwise by government county council
through their process in relation to a
temporary um
re-routing obviously right away if we
just need to
confirm the actual wording of it uh
introduction of the chair and the vice
chair
right thank you sandra
that's the better again
councillor brown councillor christie
cancer craigie or cancer leather
or pencil a lot for councillor mcgrath
councillor wiseman or
my next application convention is 116.
version of three
um
[Music]
all right
i'm now presenting that uh retrospective
application
through um changing use of uh
residential
apartments into um a house of multiple
occupancy for
eight bedroom unit on five garden
thank you so before you here's an aerial
image to show
the proposed site before you in relation
to
this uh biddeford and it's really it's
centered
within the centre of biddeford along the
back garden street
and towards the end where the junction
of meadow street to
torridge hill is as you can see through
the
location prime on the right hand side is
red outline that indicates the site
the site is currently a used as a
licensed
hmo to serve uh eight
individuals residents there the site is
operated by the biddeford lighthouse
project
as which is an independent non-profit
organization
that provides uh supportive housing for
adult men
who are seeking to recover from
addictions whether it be agile or drug
related and it's a project that provides
that assisted
living and support for up to eight
residents
to seek a pathway onto rehabilitation
to live independent lives going into the
future
and they do provide support beyond
beyond
current residence occupation of the site
uh the site is um managed um
with uh staffing facilities and office
space and there's
a member of staff there throughout the
duration of the day
and there's out of power support as well
for the residents
the only physical operation of the site
is
the removal of the internal fire doors
or the previous masonette flats
and a reference waste store in the
garden which i'll show you some photos
now
please so the
little lighthouse project is the blue
building
within the street so this is back garden
street and the view towards
torres hill bedroom street junction
here's a view from the junction on
magnum street toys hill
looking back along the back garden
street water pannier market way
and they're building as i said before
the blue one within the
street next slide please
and here's another street scene view
just
show the different types of built form
and how well they're maintained within
the
street garden towards the market
centre of biddeford thank you
and uh here's some photos of the
principal and rear elevations
as you can see the building is well kept
within the conservation area of
biddeford
and retaining the character of the site
and here's rear just to show you the
waste storage of the site
and private uh courtyard immunity space
for the residents
and then he's voted to show um a garage
actually used or rented as a part of
the lighthouse project to provide
storage or community
and personal items for residents as well
as recreational
fishing cycling surfboards and
slime please and
this is from that rear courtyard that
just shows the relationship
to the neighbouring property so to the
on the left-hand side just shows a high
wall relationship to
that's towards the north and then to the
south is the other
rear properties that site relates to
and here's a list of registered hmos
within torridge
um this was provided from the housing
mill and this is also publicly
accessible the underlying yellow
indicates
um hmos within biddeford to take into
account
the cumulative impact which was raised
as a concern
within the calling and um
maybe within the calling reason
apologies so
i've got the following slide shows of
the um locations of where these hmos are
and predominantly they're concentrated
towards a high street
where there's a higher occupation of up
to i think the most
densely populated one is 16.
and then where our site is is the bottom
there there's
uh number five but garden street which
is the application before you
and then also number 15 but garden
street is an existing hmo
and then along meadow street there is
another hmo of six
so go on to forward
so the main considerations before you
are the principal development
the site is proposed as a hmo albeit
it is managed by an independent
organization
and to provide sort of specialist
support for which serves
residents within north devon and
torridge but wider beyond the south west
it is a licensed hmo it will be
retrospective
for the planning side of things and just
to clarify
we do not have any specific uh
restrictions on hmo or specific policies
for hmos
in terms of assessing the density uh
within
a specific proximity nonetheless um
up to five residents can live in a
hmo without the need for planning
permission so
just to bear in mind in terms of
consideration of the application
uh in terms of character and appearance
within the conservation area
as you may appreciate a bit from the
fade says the building is
well kept and reflects a traditional
appearance within the
uh the surrounding area amenity concerns
were raised with recall in terms of
potential
anti-sociable behavior arising from the
premises
as a part of the consultation and the
police liaison officer was consulted
and initially raised no objections to
the scheme
this was further followed up given the
calling for committee
and uh further investigations within the
consultation raised that there was
no registered incidences associated with
this specific
um site
and within the wider area of that garden
street
there was only one within the past four
years
and the officer goes on to say there's a
perception it's a transient area
so um there may be a perceived
anti-social behavior associated with
that with that part of
good but actually there isn't any
substantial evidence to demonstrate
this has given rise to that and uh there
was further letters of support to say
from the immediate properties there was
no concerns with
the um the operations since 2016
of this site um and highways the site is
in the sustainable location where
there isn't a requirement for provision
of parking
um because it's accessible to
sustainable those transport
and ecology the site is retrospective
and it's not considered there to be any
harm as a result of protected species so
thank you for listening i'll pass back
to the channel thank you
angelo thank you we've got two speakers
this application the first one is adam
langer in support of the application
if you'd like to come forward
um sit there or
which of you can vote or have a yellow
spot it's just so everybody can hear you
up here
and you've got three minutes to address
the committee
thank you um i'm adam langer i'm the
managing director of the bit of the
lighthouse project and i set the project
up
to speak up because
i'm adam langer i'm the managing
director of the biddeford lighthouse
project and i set the project up
just to give a little bit of background
i gave evidence of the home affairs
select committee on drug treatment
in 2012 i've worked in supportive
housing worked in residential drug
treatment
and worked in family assessment and
intern as a project so um
um hmo properties where addicts live
tend to be thought of as like hostels
you'll get a lot of noise a lot of
problems coming out of them we are
nothing like that at all
so i very carefully designed a process
where there's very little money for drug
treatment in the uk now
and what can you do within the supported
housing sector within the legislation
which actually helps people really make
changes and we developed a model where
we provide supportive housing for a
mutual aid community
and we have complete autonomy on who
comes into the house so when we do our
assessments
we're assessing people that we believe
are willing to engage and actually work
with us
we have a complete no time alcohol use
in or out of the house um and
um so i'm a qualified bacd corporate
psychotherapist my colleagues got a
degree in addictions counseling we don't
need that for the jobs that we're doing
but that's the level of seriousness that
is going on within our project
um we've had as i'm sure you've seen in
the documents i've got support from the
bridge trust from the police there's no
noise that comes even the neighbors are
saying there's no problem
um and we so we're independent so we're
with so a lot of the sported housing
projects um
are funded through the old supporting
people money
um for torridge we are completely free
to torridge we are paid for completely
by central government
housing benefit money we're looking to
blueprint
how can we get the best outcomes for
that money that's the attitude
we have to the work that we're doing
there
[Music]
all of our residents engage in voluntary
i'd say
over covered we weren't able but
generally all of our residents would do
voluntary work within the community
[Music]
let's say um so in terms of code 19 we
operate as a family as a community
we've maintained a bubble throughout and
so in turn i i saw something about kind
of the way that we have shared
facilities
um i've got we had two hundred thousand
pounds of social enterprise funding
for the player flight house project i've
got 500 000 pounds of funding
for a new lighthouse project i'm looking
for buildings with shared facilities
because we operate as a family
we create a community atmosphere so
people have got their own bedrooms their
own private spaces
but we're not limiting on we're not
trying to shortchange anybody
we have a very specific model and we
want the interaction with people
with because we're not we're not a rehab
we need them to engage in cooking meals
for each other and
sitting together and having the kind of
problems that come up or sharing being
in the bathrooms and having chronic
problems come up
because that's where we can support them
to grow and learn and develop
um you know when what is there to say
you know we're free to the community
we're autonomous we're doing really good
work in there i was the one who messed
up i didn't realize that we need
planning i've got the hmi license i
thought
that's all that was needed and you know
we're doing great work out there we're
um and the kind of problems that you'll
have coming out with
possibly some other hmos in the areas
and solve those problems we take those
people
and we really turn them around and be
like i hope you can hear from me i'm
speaking from my heart i'm passionate
about
i'm 21 years old 21 years ago
you know recovery
to turn their lights around so does
everybody else who works in the project
we've got an embarrassed one about all
the directors and manager of the
residential drug treatment center
we're really serious about what we do
please facts
our next speaker to this application is
the council of boston award members
good afternoon i understand you've had
an entertaining morning
and as i said the chair has said i'm a
bit of a north councillor
uh and i'd just like to draw your
attention to the fact that black garden
street
is very much a residential street in the
center of the town
and there are a number of properties
being used to house
um certain individuals who have a range
of personal issues and
i have every sympathy with the issues
that they have
alcohol and dependency being just two
there is also a home for young for young
people with
a range of problems as well um a block
of flats
currently is fairly close to the
development that goes now and all of
these
properties are all causing a lot of
unease for the residents of neighboring
um both in uh
garden street torres street and normandy
and
in my personal opinion to add another
property with eight individual units
another hmo
will only add to the many issues that
are currently raised
um it's it's been said just now that the
police
don't have any concerns in particular
with
this i find that hard to believe because
over the last
year or so the police have responded to
any number of incidents
in i'm not saying it's anything to do
with this particular
application but nevertheless the police
are frequent visitors
to buck garden street uh church walk
and in the actual church yard itself i
personally have witnessed um on several
occasions
um drug dealing within the town which i
have reported to
so in in the church yard um
a lot of the people exit the church uh
enter the church yard
from a buck garden street and
steps into tower street um so clearly
there are there's
a lot of issues that are going on within
the buck garden street area
and i think to add another
uh large hmo to what is already uh
over density of that type of uh property
within
within the town center the high street
has got many
garden street has 47. i think the
previous slide that angelo put up
showing
the the six properties the six hmos all
within a couple of hundred yards of each
other
tells you the kind of density that we've
got i don't know if any other tone and
torridge
has anything like the number of hmos
that we have in the town
um i can't believe one moment that
they're all
um are all housing local people that
were born and bred in this area clearly
i think we are importing
a lot of people from outside of uh the
you know the torridge area
and i think if you put up another 10
hmos within the town
within a short space of time i'm sure
you would feel them as well
i just think this is like one
development
too far we've recently um
as a as an authority we've got a public
space protection order
in place um after many years of
being like one uh and you have to ask
yourself
you know why a pspo is needed in the
center of biddeford
clearly you know it's not for
um your outreach families that you know
you have something added in place but
mainly is because you know we have such
a large number
of individuals that have you know very
very unfortunately
um you know a lot of a lot of personal
issues and i
i i totally applaud what the previous
speaker uh
is trying to do to help people and i
think
it needs to be spread around the
district far more than what it is rather
than concentrating
everything and putting with 10 seconds
and i'll leave it there
thank you thank you
that's that's our last speaker
throw it over to the discussion just
remind everybody it is a planning
application
retrospective planning application to
change the three flats into the eight
headsets
[Music]
um i think it's brilliant work that
they're doing
and i think we should be encouraging
people like that who are making an
effort to help us
and the people the people who we've got
with problems
the state is clearly not providing
enough help for people
that's why we've got a lot of people in
the town
drinking and taking drugs because
they're not getting any help
and to say that this is just bringing
them in for that five i think it's
completely wrong
and i i think you know we're absolutely
dependent on challenges like that
who are doing absolutely wonderful work
and i absolutely fully support them
even though my son lives on butt garden
street he has
no objections and he's had no problems
with anybody from any of the um
hmos like you can't say great what we
did see on
angelo's presentation there's the two
high holes in black garden stream and i
do think
whoever uses that garden street coming
up from the town
don't necessarily come to those islands
but is a planning application
retrospective want to turn
three flats into the eight bedsides
council bennington
very good chair i just want some
clarification um
uh both on the gray area on page 116
where you've got the setup for the
application
and again on the on on the following
page what
is a change from c3
and what does su generis
mean actually in planning terms just can
you explain that to me
in the words i understand i apologize i
should but i don't
so in terms of what plans classification
c3 means a residential dwelling house
right and then the sewer gymnast is
anything
that doesn't fall within a specific news
class so
something that's unique and in this
instance uh
an 8-bit hmo is considered to be that
sort
does it falls outside of a used class so
it's in
terms of engineers because it's a unique
alternative
use i note that it was a doctor's before
chair
prior to 1918 nine
so it's almost like going back to its
original use maybe
is that too much of a circular argument
to make i wonder
i'll leave it there
yeah i've got a clear dual mule hatted
on this it has come before the town
council planning committee
um a couple of things um firstly my
daughter actually used to live in
one of these flats so i do know the
building i've actually been in it
um some time ago but i was slightly
worried when i looked at the planning
history of this
you know there's one retrospective of
the existing local use and now is
another retrospective which always
you know it does worry you slightly um
i have to say i agree with councillor
bushby i've had lots and lots
of emails and complaints about what goes
on in black garden street
i'm not saying they all come from these
places because we don't know
quite where they come from although some
do we we know
that the thing that
worries me slightly what we didn't see
in the presentation
yet we did have at the town council we
had the internal
layout of this primo
and that does worry me because this is
i think there's one kitchen or one
bathroom it
it seemed to be fairly excessive in
terms of numbers to me
as though they were trying to crowd them
in and i i accept what the gentleman
said about you know sharing
life experiences and that that's great
but do we have actually uh
do we have a slide of the internal
layout my apologies
i made a mistake quite much sharing
the floor plans for the presentation and
in terms of internal photos and it was
appropriate to share
some of those however i can
just explain i did a georgian site visit
with our housing renewal officer
to see because a hmo license was issued
for this property so for it to actually
operate it as hmo
in the first instance it has to meet set
criteria
i'm not professionally able to comment
on
on the appropriateness of that but the
comments from the housing
new office deemed this facilities
were about uh the standards required to
meet that hmo license and
it's still valid in terms of the site
was it
there's a basement where the kitchen
layout is that leads into the
rear courtyard area and then the upper
pools are residential and there was i
believe there was
three bathrooms so as a bathroom on
every floor
when
to manage the facility and in terms of a
wider
thing like it was maybe going beyond the
application but to make you aware
when i spoke to colleagues in housing
renewal
and the authority has a right to
withdraw hmo
licenses if there are specific problems
issues with specific
properties and so that's just something
that maybe
consideration and right in terms of the
term foreign
there is more than just one much
yes
[Music]
i showed you some photos earlier
and see where the office facility is
and then you've got sufficient bedroom
spaces
which are above the space stand is
required
to serve each individual unit and
we've got the first floor plan which
shows the communal
internal living space that's to the rear
of the properties they've got the new
wave of the estuary from that space
as well as another bathroom and then two
bedrooms
on that floor and then the up drawer
again
as i said has a shared bathroom facility
with
all veterans faces that do provide
a more satisfactory
space with rituals as well as new space
as well
facilities
just the masos could i write this though
yeah okay
yeah um this is the rest
retrospective for bands so what would
what is actually current ones at the
moment
and that that is this
it and you know that minutes coming late
stages came through
and obviously the conservation area that
it is i want to make sure it's not too
much
internal knocking around this building
entirely
yeah but what is it so far what they've
changed
[Music]
how it used is operate and within
poverty it has been decorated and
renovated
to just a modern standard and in terms
of other operations
that was a small install which you saw
with the tree coming at
[Music]
yes
now you're quite lucky today do you have
all three bit of the north members here
board members and that knows me
there is an effect on immunities of the
residents who live in the street
but that effect being the anti-social
behavior aspect of it we're not saying
specifically this area
or there's specific this application in
front of us
but it's a general use i live around a
corner from there and
i don't agree what the response was on
the base actually not at all
if you look at it here the second
response having forwarded details onto
local offices we'll go actually as soon
as possible
however either used by limited limited
skills
that's a great concerning straight way
to interrogate our system
and one directly linked incident well
luckily enough i've been loved to talk
to the previous police inspector there's
been
numerous numerous complaints about this
area
i'm not saying just for the hmr but
we've got a problem with an attack
okay and so that's one thing i've always
raised it up from there
and basically what i see as
you you're chucking in eight there's
eight men
being chucked into a building it's like
a battery ends being chucked into the
house
now that also brings me in top of this
page
is this is from our housing renewal
officer
i personally think this is actually
disgusting i want to put on records i'm
saying this as well
if the application were to be rejected
the project still stands i've got no
issue with that orbit
with limited number of tenants then we
get on to the
degree the financial impact we were not
aware of however
if it were to become financially
unviable
then what message are we sending to
society you must also raise the question
of course
is this a form of discrimination
why the hell is that even on an
application in the worded way it is
worded unprofessionally we've got judy
keff he means the president should be
surrounded area as well
and i i do speak very strongly but i've
been a ward member and actually on his
application
that this here this report from the
housing officer
i'd love to know who the housing officer
is because i actually want to put
official complaint against that
i don't give a
the actual the actual material
the actual material considerations
and i just remind all members including
councilman golf you've plenty of time to
look at these plans i go on and i'm sure
the members do at home go on and look at
them and you can see all this i mean i
look at every application
i thought you probably would do as well
before we come to the transparency
and that's an opportunity all of us have
got so long
um yeah just go i've just got one what
two queries really um
i know that the police officer said he
can only relate one
case of marshall years particularly
related to this property
so they can't really pinpoint where all
the other
you know the all the other instances
came from
um and i know that the benefit trusts
have already financed this project
so they must be in favor of it um my one
query is
on page under 19 licensing
no representative no representation
received now if this property needs a
license to operate
why didn't they offer a response and
what sort of license have they got at
the moment
and that's already in situ and was
issued in 2016
so in terms of the license and
what they would require it was in the
response
from the housing renewal cell
was most appropriate in terms of
ensuring that
the current hmo license they've got
remains that it's still valid so when we
conducted the site business an
assessment to
ensure the license acquisition 2016
still remain balanced in terms of the
facilities and so on
and in situ within the building
and it was still valid
so if this license was issued in 2016
has it taken this organization four
years to put in a respective planning
application
it's taken that time but i i can't
specifically comment on that
it's just covered before me as an
application um
over the previous months so
that time friends and speaker
and language mentioned you know
the works was undertaken i know the
planning permission was
required and when it was mentioned uh
when you realized that there was a need
for it it's been applied retrospectively
right yeah a couple of things uh
thank you for letting me speak again um
the british trust has been mentioned by
the acting and by council lot
uh having just been i've been on the
british arts for a long time just being
chairman
um we don't look at planning
applications on the basis of
giving out grants we give them on the
basis of social need
so we it it doesn't imply
we support what's been going on in terms
of
the planning it doesn't apply in terms
of social um
one of the problems that
i suspect my other two north wall
councils have come across
is that charis house which is the
longest established
hmi hr h-i-m-o for
people with problems which is down the
other end of black valley street
one of the problems is all their clients
come from elsewhere
they are deliberately brought there
because it's to get them out of their
circle
and you know which you can see why but
one of the problems is
that i get it i can't speak about two
counts i expect they have
it is that people say why are we
bringing
problems into benefit because we never
seem to send
our problem people out they're always
hanging about i recognize them all the
time they never go we seem to get more
um and this is one of the issues that
does come up quite strongly actually
i i know you probably can't ask the
applicant now where his clients come
from but
i suspect they're not local because it
would make sense
not to happen local really but this is
one of the problems that we are faced
with as councillors
but you see all these people coming up
with problems who aren't local
at all i i like to think we're a caring
community in benefit and that's why
we've got this but you heard from
councillor craig he's got relatively
winning rock garden street
and we've got the evidence on what's put
here by the designer at crime officer
i do think looking at what's been done
changing through flats into these eight
bedrooms
and i think it looks it's been an ex
excellent the inside of the
provision of the shared space and i can
understand the reasons
for having the shared spaces but there's
plenty of bathroom spaces in there as
well
it has been moved and secondly cancelled
i peninsula listening to the spell just
around the table here it's very
interesting feeling of a discussion
there's ten elected members here of
which
three represent the one war that they're
there and they're of a common voice
and i am aware that we're going to come
to a decision in a minute
and maybe it would almost be like and
i'm not prejudging how the vote may go
um but it almost feel like what the rest
of torrents may do to another part of
torridge
and uh
not one
i appreciate that but there's been a lot
of talk about situations of
what's not been actually attached to
five but
garden stream and i have to be totally
honest
i don't go into benefit of an evening
now at all i avoid with the fruit of the
evening
and that takes business away from biddy
fruit
and that is the personal reaction i look
at the issues
raised here and i know christopher golf
has talked about the
comment from the housing renewal officer
but
we still have no direct link between
the uh occurrence of difficult
incidences being linked to to five but
garden street
and i also know by the representations
here looking at representations
eight neighbors consulted and
six represented received five letters
supporting
now that is a pretty strong no that's
not a planning reason you're going to
tell me that sort of planning reason
but they are not because their responses
have come back
okay but what i'm coming to is why isn't
more people
neighboring making comments on the
negative side
had that been put forward i just wonder
where the balance
and there has to be a balance because
the police
have made comment to one direct incident
but nothing else
and yes we can have a general discussion
about where
i agree i listen to the pranksters here
but i also have to say
well what is the evidence here and i
i don't have that evidence to link what
you're saying to
to the lighthouse project um
to to the comments going around the
table and i'm actually quite torn i'm
still thinking which way
am i going to vote when i come to this
slope because i don't want it to be a
situation
where you know the ones that i want to
vote against to support my colleagues
but even a bigger burden on me is is we
have a duty to all members of society
because we're all
equal in the sight of whatever creator
you believe you're going to say
and that's where we come from so there
was a balance there to be struck
and that might be a planning reason but
that one everybody back to the fact that
this is a planning application
and if you look at if you look at the
plumbing reasons
for turning three facts you either agree
with that where you don't
as far as amenity effect on the amenity
of the area
there's been a lot of hearsay what a
supposition the only evidence we've got
is written in the report
i mean we've heard what one of the board
members we addressed as
says but i i would just say
look at it as a planning do you not want
this turning into a bedroom did this
it has been done this is retrospective
[Music]
are we being asked to approve or not
what is physically being done from the
building or are we being asked
to approve its use now we've
been asked to approve that this has been
turned from three flats into a
house of multiple occupation
and that's the eight bedrooms that are
there in the bathrooms
which have been done so
[Music]
please
i guess cancer wiseman cancer pennington
four that's seven
four chair and two against thank you
thank you okay we're all here um ryan
thank you you're presenting
me apple your application thank you
chair
so um as described i'm doing the
application for torridge garage and
torrid in ecuador the demolition of an
existing garage and erection
dwelling so as you can see on these
slides the site is located sort of
north and northwest of capital car park
is sort of located along that sort of
broader end of the torah trade obviously
we went through some of these slides
yesterday
um these images sort of indicate
the conservation area luckily we have
the conservation officer here today
and the conservation area is sort of
marked by that sort of red line
and the right image is indicates all the
list of buildings as part
as part of the um indicated by blue
triangles
uh this is location plan next slide
and this is the block plan um
[Music]
next slide and this is the site plan
just important to note at this point and
obviously the property is at split level
and so uh so you've got the original
ground floor section as we go through
the other drawings and then you've got
sort of a first floor edition
on top on top uh next slide
and these are the lower ground floor
plans and the ground floor plans
um interesting to note that there is a
garage included on that ground floor
and this is a first floor plan which
includes filling and dining room
lounge areas um next slide
and these are the elevation drawings um
so yeah as you can see you've got that
that garage on the ground floor
sort of as sort of described yesterday
you've got
the building so on the left hand side
you've got
the the application site and proposal
before it's here and then
on the left and you've got a planning
permission approval for a workshop
garage that was approved um i think
this year and that that's the front
elevation and then the images on the
right indicate that the rear elevation
which includes obviously that
that monopicks roof um with some timber
slats on that sort of middle section
and along with um sort of natural stone
at the bottom
um these are sort of section drawings or
side elevation drawings
and interesting things from my
conversations with um
counselor christy yesterday about the
sort of street scene potential impact
i think i'd like to clarify at this
point that the proposed
redevelopment of the site has not moved
from where the existing site was
secondly i think important to know i've
got some some measurements which
might help indicate this situation i
think that right section drawing
actually helps to show
what the situation is quite well so at
the ground floor bit
the existing ground floor height of the
existing garage is 3.7 meters
high and this proposed redevelopment
would actually reduce that because of
the parapet
of having a monopitch roof um at that
point
um of that first ground floor bit um the
next addition
or the first floor extension is set 2.7
meters back
and then increases again in height i
think
um uh
2.9 meters in height so obviously
you know at that low it will be lower
level at the start of the
of the refund and then at first full
level it's set back and so it should
sort of fall within line
with some of the other dwellings along
that long way street scene
next slide this is another section
drawing available to you you can still
see the context of the other dwellings
and torrid road to your right and and
the property known as single which will
see some images of the as i've
already described to you and sort of
actually stream to the left-hand side of
that image so next slide
is a 3d montage of the post development
from
um from a lower perspective and of the
rear elevation
so you can sort of see that monitoring
and some of those design features there
next slide please and this is a view
from the estuary
helpfully provided by the conservation
officer so you've got the
um more up-to-date image on the bottom
um
just some random arrows but i can
explain to you what they
mean the purple arrow reflects the
application
site the red arrow reflects the property
known as sanger which is a
a flat roof dwelling
and rather insignificant in design terms
and the blue arrow which is a recent
redevelopment
or i would say last five to ten years
redevelopment
of a property um called two rivers
um the adjacent dwelling which is that
sort of dormant roof
uh i think you could just zoom in there
shawn
that also has planning permission that
was approved last year
and i can give you the details uh
replacement dwelling for a
flat roof uh remodelization of that
property as well um so next slide for
john
this is the site so this is the existing
garage as you can see it's
i'm in quite poor condition
and actually because i've tried to
detail this more report as a result of a
lot of the modernization storage road
actually appears quite in congress out
of proportion
with the rest of torres road um and
i think i think it is a good opportunity
to reach about the site
uh as you move on next slide for sure
again another image from side elevation
obviously important to note that this
from this perspective um the land slope
so it is higher at this
point of of turret road um so
on the other side you know where the
lady is standing that would be
the 3.5 3.7 meters
and on that sort of wall facing the
droneway
that would be um closer to 4.2
next slide please this is inside
at ground floor level if you come in
from torridge road
and as you can see it's just being used
for storage around bits and pieces
um looks like official and this is a
view out
outside at that level uh the windows are
out the back there
of the of the garden and then the
current immunity area
as you can see you've got those
properties from commercial street in the
background
and next slide pretty sure and these are
just an array of images which you would
have seen yesterday
i'm standing in the middle of the main
sierra sort of panning around so
north northwest
the next one uh northeast
the east southeast
and it's light and sort of south west
and moving just moving back across
really
there we are and obviously that's um
a corrugated building which sort of sits
on that sort of left-hand side of the
site as you look out
and make slightly visual and this is
sort of inside that lower ground floor
level
as you can see it's sort of build built
out of
[Music]
an array of material um and is obviously
just
continue to be used for storage purposes
next slide
this is the the wall to the east of the
site and
as you can see some some tend to repair
the wall
um and that's the sort of drain way that
sort of runs parallel to the side
slightly sure now this is the property
known as sanger which i described before
from perspectives of the s3 this is the
the main sort of dwelling you sort of
see behind the site obviously the
proposed redevelopment as you can see
with some of the drawings
does lift the dwelling but i don't think
it particularly harms that sort of
perspective from
from the conservation area impact or
from the estuary so
next likely sure and yeah and these are
just some examples of some images of
some of the
redevelopments along along torres road
so this is two rivers
as you can see quite prominent against
the road and so we're talking about that
sort of building scale and massing and
it's
it's obviously um yeah next cycle
and uh yeah that's a strong team that's
been redeveloped and
or may be developed on the backstabbing
mission
uh this is a image sort of moving up
towards road towards
uh sort of away from that car park and i
think next slide looks back
towards us so as you can see uh in the
distance
um you could zoom in shawn that's that
that's the garage there
the monica troop against the sort of
gable i'm dwelling there
from next to the suction conditioner
these are going to take material
planning considerations thank you time
i'm happy to answer questions
thank you everyone thank you for that
we've got one speaker to this
application it's board member councillor
hey
um as a ward member i'm not i'm
uneasy about some of the issues relating
to the application
for you some of which have been raised
by northern town council
in recommending refusal i should state
however that i've reconsidered some of
the reasons i gave the calling
and decided not to raise it at this
committee
having said this i do still query the
case officers and applicants assertion
that the present building is in a
dilapidated state
physical inspection of the exterior and
interior of the building and inspection
of photographic evidence supplied
by the applicant passed out on the
assertion
and to my knowledge the building has
over the years been a useful score and
workshop
including id for the maintenance of or
construction of boats
given this may i point out there are
there are very few such buildings left
in aberdorn and as such these buildings
have great practical value in what is
historically
an important boat building village and
where there is a need for workshop
infrastructure
to support local employment i should
refer also
to the wildlife aspect there's reference
to swallows nesting
in the building and possibly not there
now
but i do query why there isn't any
provision for biodiversity gain in the
application
i also know the building has been used
as a garage and from the photos and the
design and access statement
it looks like three vehicles could be
accommodated in it
given a severe shortage of garage and
parking space in aberdour i again
suggest that the existing building is
great practical value
and i disagree with the case officer
applicant in conservation office that of
course the character of epidural may
have changed this
that this negates the need for this
useful building
my comment also relates directly to the
provision of only one parking space
allowed for the proposed four-bedroom
dwelling this should bring alarm bells
with you if you consider the huge
pressure on street parking in april
and specifically in torrid road where
there is already a parking problem
as a result of other new developments
approved by torridge
in this respect it's disturbing to read
in the applicant's design and access
statement
there is an abundance of street parking
in torres road
and also to read the suggestion that
cars from the dwelling could be parked
in the car park
surely this fails to comply with local
plant policy gm06
para1248 and dn04 power h regarding the
need to provide proper parking
provision with the development and of
course the surplus cars will add even
more pressure on apple doors highly
stressed parking situation
i therefore submit to that that as the
present building has space to
accommodate three vehicles it is in
respect
parking more sustainable than the replay
proposed
as to the design of the building i share
northern town council's concerns that it
would have
would have an adverse impact on the
street scene
primarily because the large areas of
placing and the roof design
both features which in my view clash
with the neighboring properties on that
side of torridge road
which have limited glazing and pitched
roofs and i'll refer here to policy tm04
a b and d in this respect i query why
the conservation officer has chosen to
relate the design of the new building to
the more recent developments
further along and on the other side of
the road
i also draw your attention here to the
committee report when the officer says
the proposed design would match a
proposed building next door to the site
for which orange is given planning
permission
however i do query the relevance of this
comment given that the approved building
has
yet been built surely shouldn't one
comment on a proposed building's
relationship
to what is already built or not to what
has permission to be built
i also refer to the apple door area
design statement
the document which seems to be rarely
looked at by
the planning committee which is a
supplementary planning document
this states that new buildings in the
village should respond to the character
and context of the setting
that the design should provide an easy
transition between neighbouring
buildings
and that elevation should respect the
proportions of avian buildings
i therefore submit the proposed dwelling
does not fit these criteria
china regarding lp policy sg17 on
housing balance
which states development should reflect
local housing needs
i do query the need for a four-bedroom
house in april
when the village is crying out for
affordable housing
i hope you'll give serious
considerations of the concerns i've
raised
and require the applicant to come back
with a proposal that complies with the
policies
i've referred to thank you thank you
councilman
right i'll throw it up into
[Music]
the comments of the committee
hasn't gone thanks sir can we go back
this is a slightly
even history piece
the purple line is the perspective yeah
that's the application side so you can
obviously see that a lot of pictures
there which is something we've been keen
to keep
as part of the proposed redevelopment um
yeah yeah i mean that that's a question
for me though the view from the
yesterday there then obviously
is the detail report from the uh
conservation officer yeah
you know a lot of potentially gone into
it and you can see if i look at that
scene myself
would he obviously i could have the
largest back there
you know there's me there imposing
houses but this
it blends in that's my view of blends in
when i said
i think the conservation officer did a
good job but it's actually a nice
positive report i've been very good
thank you for coming in thank you
coaching cough anybody else make coming
well counselors yeah um i
think that highways have got no
objections because they actually state
that that hasn't been used as a garage
for some time
so you're not actually losing any
on-road parking
because the new um development will
provide some off-road market
and i also um commend the conservation
officer on a report it's very positive
and i agree with councilman it fits in
well
um with regard to the design of
materials this is always going to be an
emotive issue because what one likes the
other doesn't like so that you know in
the end that comes down to personal
opinion
so i would recommend approval of the
application
thank you councillor
can we can we go back to the
uh the one showing me step
back you know that you mentioned because
up there
that's it because i know councillor
christie mentioned
on the site visit yesterday about street
scene
and ryan in his presentation did say
that
the height at the front there now would
be slightly lower
than they existed and then it steps back
to come more in line with what's already
and then it goes higher again there so
i think the effect on the streets and
let me show the drawings
from the street to
anything surely there's an improvement
on what's there but there we are
that one there one on the left there so
the height of that front there and then
it steps back to where you can see
this window there the other one on the
left is what's already been
approved but not yet no well i'll settle
cancel a lot because i think
this is going to be improvement in
helping the concept
i think it's very brave to plan for
currently that much
when you look at the stage i'll second
cancel
recommendations to prove anybody else
want to make comment
council mcgovern have you any more you
wanted to go certainly you just touched
it mr german
you just you distressed what i want
there are all right yeah
right nobody else wants to make a
comment on it
it's been recommended by councillor and
i've seconded it
things so yes thank you chair councillor
chairman councillor brown councillor
christie
or chancellor craigie or cancer leather
or chancellor for councillor mcgowan
paul cancer wiseman paul councillor
pennington
unanimous thank you so much
[Music]
um i sat through two solid days of this
here and it was all legal and not
actually planned
so it's very difficult to sit for two
days and concentrate
um i did bring up the officer who uh
presented the case at the hearing chris
evelyn
and did congratulate him on an excellent
job and i know that dalton parish
council
also sent a letter to torrid and thanked
him for
thanking them for all their hard work
and taking the battle forward
where did they hold this thing where did
they hold this
what why did they hold this inquiry
delegated decisions agm
bombs there item 11.
the plain decisions made between the
19th of march and the 11th of may
page 114. sorry just one yeah
the bottom one um
because when you read the actual report
it's more than twice the number of
houses
actually in the area and i just can't
believe the
flight didn't come to committing
150 851
152 153
1546
157
[Music]
161 162
163 164
and 165
we've got one notches
there's only a few but you can see once
again that visit
how incredibly busy they're planning
department
thank you very you for any of the much
which stayed with this um dislocated
plans committee meeting
that we got there in here